more rioting in portland as andy fought
barricaded doors to police buildings and
courthouses that
taxpayers built and then set the
structures on fire
or as the media describes it nothing
special
yeah if you're looking for this on the
news good luck it's tucked away
behind slabs of mary trump's bitter
psychoanalysis
but when the media is forced to cover it
they say the same thing
the response to riots is actually worse
than the riots themselves
at cnn apologists for rioting call
right-wing coverage of it
a gross exaggeration
there are real problems in portland but
it is made up on fox news like it's this
raging fire
out of control and that is a gross
exaggeration
it just is it's a gross exaggeration
that should be the name of his show but
it's nothing new
remember cnn mocking the rise in violent
crime
democratic cities are in chaos right now
is this what you want from joe biden and
they're going to take your country away
and they're taking down the statues and
crime is rising
oh my gosh it's so bad and they get
defunding police
it's like
wow beavis and butthead i guess to an
idiot that's funny
but remember it's the crime that they
mock that brings the police in to stop
it
which increases the chances for
encounters that can go wrong
but dismissing real violence in favor of
mocking the concern for it
saves them from examining their own role
in protecting the mob and stoking
violence
oh yes i don't condone violence they
plea unless
i agree with the violence and please
show me where it says that protests are
supposed to be polite
and peaceful but i argue to you tonight
all punches
are not equal morally in the eyes of the
law
yes fighting hate is right
and in a clash between hate and those
who oppose it
those who oppose it are on the side of
right so why
this pathetic appeasement well they're
petty
if they were to defend law and order the
police or even you the citizen
that puts them on the same side as trump
they'd rather jump into bed with violent
scum
cnn bends over backwards to hide the
crime
behind this media criticism claiming
that covering the violence is meant to
smear a movement and therefore
condemning mayhem
has to be racist no we say we're just
looking at what's happening to a country
that we dearly love and we are worried
sick about it
we're actually scared but go on and
laugh
and then call 9-1-1 when this hell comes
to your house
so uh i want to play this tape from the
portland police union boss darrell
turner juan and then i want to get your
reaction let's go
our elected officials have condoned the
destruction and chaos of our city
they have placed their political agendas
ahead of the safety of all of us and the
welfare of the community
this must stop so juan what
what do you think local officials need
to be doing now
well i mean local officials need to deal
with local problems greg that's the
point here
i mean i want to talk to you about two
videos i don't know if we have them but
one video is of david
uh chris david who is a veteran of the
navy he appears before
these un unidentified federal groups
and he's wearing a navy t-shirt he's got
a backpack on his back that says navy
he just wants to talk and they begin
beating and gassing the man
uh how about a second video this one of
another man mark pettibone
he's in the video walking away when an
unmarked car shows up grabs him men in
camouflage again
grab and throw him in an unmarked car
and he later says they just released him
so he's never charged with anything he
doesn't know who they were or what
happened
so incidents like those are why you have
the oregon attorney general
suing homeland security it's why the
aclu is filing lawsuits
in these suits they argue that local
matters
should be handled by local authorities
and the local authorities
the mayor the governor both senators
want trump's troops off the street what
they say is here's
mayor ted wheeler he says the feds
are provoking violence escalating the
vandalism
governor kate brown said this is
political theater staged by trump to
divide the country
and create a campaign issue in which
trump can play
law and order hero but it's an abuse of
federal power and oftentimes i hear
conservatives say
hey what about states rights well
nothing this time
so i would just ask everyone what are
tactical units
tactical units from border patrol and
immigration
customs doing in the streets of portland
oregon
that's an abuse of power
because anarchy means no one is safe and
they're trying to preserve order that's
what it's there for
emily in seattle 12 cops were injured
uh there were more riots in looting of
course if we try to
stop that we're invading a local problem
according to wand
right well i disagree
one respectfully what we are seeing on
the streets
those are federal crimes throwing
explosives falls under title 18
that is a federal crime and deserves a
federal response
because the local leadership is not
doing anything and they are not
allowing that local law enforcement to
protect its citizens
the full out attack on law enforcement
and cities
that footage we are looking at that is
undeniable
and for these feckless invertebrate
governors
and mayors to try to pivot to the
national government and saying that it's
some type of federal overreach
when they are failing their communities
is absolutely ludicrous
we are watching a war on the streets we
are watching officers being killed
and i am one of those seattle residents
who is watching this city
being destroyed alongside livelihoods
while mayor durkin
and mayor wheeler play ftse with the
mainstream media
or their insular socialist married band
of pilgrims
because they just want to get reelected
or answer to their small
electoral i have to point out that
regardless how you feel about this
president or this administration
we need help these cities are being
overrun by organized
anarchists while homeless and drug
addicts are allowed to fester in these
quote safe
cities all of the politicization needs
to be put aside because we need help
and it is not coming from local
leadership
jesse you know that the local leadership
is desperate if they're trying somehow
to link their own incompetence to trump
that somehow this is his fault federal
agents are there to protect federal
property and they're not trump's
troopers juan they're called federal
protective service
they're there to protect federal
infrastructure they're from the
department of
homeland security and the hatfield
courthouse is a federal district
courthouse
in the city of portland and it's been
vandalized they've had
windows broken they've had a bulletproof
door smashed through with hammers these
anarchists are trying to literally
take over a federal building so they're
there to protect the federal building
and when these federal agents are there
to protect federal property
they've had lasers pointed into their
eyes and they've had commercial grade
fireworks shot at them these anarchists
have tried to hit people with vehicles
and when you come in and take some away
in a van
that's actually a traditional law
enforcement de-escalation tactic
because when someone assaults a federal
agent or
commits a crime on federal property they
need to be
arrested now there's two ways of doing
that you could send in a bunch of
federal agents
into a middle of a crowd of 100
anarchists and try to arrest an
individual
or you could isolate them later when
they're more alone and then make an
arrest
that's how good policing is done now
it's also
funny to hear the left complaint about
trump setting
federal agents anywhere after they sent
federal agents into the trump campaign
that's literally what happened they were
okay with that but he doesn't like
federal agents in portland oh my gosh
yes exactly you can't do it to protect
citizens but you can go after trump
so degen apparently it's a
arson and violence is a local problem
but police brutality is a national or
global concern
right exactly imagine being so
unswervingly steadfastly steadfastly
anti-trump that you're pro-crime
that vi that violence and looting get a
double thumbs up
from the clowns on some of these tv
networks
and their brethren run in the states and
and cities in some of these areas but it
is an
abomination to talk about enforcing
the law and fighting crime president
trump is
actually standing up for his
constitutional duty
it is to take care that the laws be
faithfully executed
and you know what these losers in places
like
no disrespect emily and washington and
oregon
are doing is they're turning their back
on their constitutional duty because
it's in the
the tenth amendment that the states um
have the right to stand up for the
safety of their citizens and the actual
duty to do that and it's perfectly okay
if federal crimes are being committed
whether it's drug crimes or the feds can
prove a racketeering enterprise
to go in with no invitation and no
permission
but i push back on one thing greg those
two are not beavis and butthead
that is an insult to mike judge
that is true i apologize let me just
quickly let me just quickly throw this
in there that let me just quickly throw
this in there that i think
local voters under that 10th amendment
have a right to hold local officials
accountable if they think they're not
doing a good job and those local
officials want to get reelected so they
are
answering to their local constituents
and one other point
you know what police brutality against
black people is a national problem
that's why i got national attention
and so are riots and so is looting and
so is violence that the
wild spikes and violence